we have to do
oh my analysis in Chicago I'm not you're
not going out let I'm sorry two and a
half year old son so I have no space
left for long time my oh I'm incredibly
dusty fellows my order I intense one of
my wardrobe from the filaments Dennis at
every movie theater but what turn
instrument than the wings and I think it
will do more damage to a person's head
so I'm thrilled
what makes exist will be dependent
having the directors passing the test
pass there was no caste attached to the
stone I am not quite sure my basic mix
about pendant and actually I think just
the way that it was done very
economically and without the kind of
names that you might sometimes
yeah I mean the whole point of this
movie was trying to create the world
that student necessarily if it wasn't
based gonna be based on natives that was
going to draw you in and just let the
story unfold right and so you know I
mean Jessica and Aaron and sariyer
Minneapolis and I think that the poems
knew that the appeal for this movie was
limited like what many independent
movies are they kept the budget down
they were insistent that those stars be
a part of it they really cast the way
they had their visit they wrote a script
with their vision and I think it
depended films stand for that kind of
thing and I think the Cohens stand for
an independent vision at because they
have power in Hollywood they every once
in a while could make a movie like this
where their vision is pure so I think
that's what makes have a dependent
a serious man best picture I'm writing
your first buddies the visual look at
the film is so amazingly distinct
saturated Tamil I am curious if any of
you kept any of your wardrobe touches
glad to hear why ensure your 5th if you
kept my sis there's very burned here as
you can see how yes i 100% got rid of my
brown I'm here in my extra 15 pounds
like as fast as possible truth be told
the 60s were not kind to human sweat
that must have been a very stinky time I
couldn't wait to get rid of my polyester
I speak for everybody else I couldn't
wait for you to get rid of your
polyester to it so no I wouldn't if you
want to see something though that is the
work of Mary's ovaries who has been
their casting director for an incredible
amount of years this is truly one of the
best things that she's done and her
sister Jenny Egan
everyone agrees with that but it really
is so much part of the film as it's
every other aspect of it it was going
somewhere
I kept my glasses three different kinds
of glasses Roger Deakins was very
particularly like the glass in the
glasses the one had the UV coating what
didn't have UV coating to wear
prescription and one was just their
glass I have them all Michael Stuhlbarg
is representing the guru so we're gonna
be it from exfoliating and my doing how
am i preparing for Sunday I'm gonna
think about all these guys and wrecking
the good karma and the thoughts with us
so thrilled that we were invited to
participate in the event you know at all
it's such a diverse collection of films
this year and all
so just think on thoughts in that great
time and
it's bread alone